hi everyone in this video we'll talk
about extracellular matrix and see what
are the components of the extracellular
matrix and what are the functions of
extracellular matrix in terms of
providing structural support and whether
do have whether they do have any
signaling role or communication role as
well so before studying extracellular
matrix we should understand a house
cannot be built on a soft ground right
it needs a strong basement upon which
the structures could be assembled and a
house could be built if this basement
structure is not there there is a
possibility that the house would
collapse similarly in case of a tissue
for example taking an example of
epithelial tissue the epithelial cell
layer cannot float around it has to be
on top of a basement and that basement
is basal lamina along with basal lamina
there are several proteinaceous
peptidoglycan and other molecular
glycosaminoglycan etc other molecular
component which makes the total basement
concrete and as a result this whole
epithelial layer could be supported on
top of this exercise the matrix
component so in this video we would talk
about the overall composition of the
extracellular matrix and the basal
lamina so here is a zoomed view you can
see the basal lamina is composed of
several fibrous materials and this basal
lamina has specific structures which are
connecting the cell to to the basal
lamina so we will see all of these
components one by one first we talked
about integrins integrins
are small proteinaceous components that
a cell has in its basal lateral side
mostly in the basal side in the basal
side the integral is composed of two
functional subunits
and alpha integral and beta integral
subunit when the alpha and beta integral
forms dimer they are active now the
Alpha integral and beta integral
composition has two states one in active
state where they are interacting with
some adapters like sharing and active
state whether they are interacting
adapters like Tallinn vinculin etc we
would look at what is the functional
role of integral in terms of providing
structural support or functionality of
the integral so integral can interact
with several structural internal
structural adapter molecules these are
after molecules are either VIN cooling
or Calvin here talon is shown in pink
and vinculin is shown in blue all these
adapter molecules help to connect the
integrins cytoplasmic domain to the
cells actin cytoskeleton network and on
the other hand side the head domain of
the integral is connected to the ECM
components that means extracellular
matrix component mainly integrally
connects with collagen fibers after in
degree we should talk about laminin
laminin is a huge coiled coil protein
structure and it has three big domains
so it has beta alpha and gamma domain
before we move on to functionality of
each domain and what it interacts with
we should know that the lamina means
belongs to glycoprotein family and they
are almost present in every organism so
next question is where does laminin come
from
it turns out the cells the epithelial
cells and many other cells secrete
laminin to be a component of the
extracellular matrix
laminin is also vital for maintenance
and survival of several tissues for
example a defective laminin can cause
several
muscular dystrophy and problems in the
myoblast laminin has three broad domains
alpha beta and gamma the alpha domain
helps to interact with the integrins
whereas BG n gamma domain are helping in
self-assembly process the coiled-coil
domain the end of the coiled-coil domain
is actually it can interact with
integrins parla cancer and district
lichens all these interaction would
ensure a laminin network would be formed
apart from laminin there is another
important structure which is known as ty
for collagen now ty for collagen are
initially monomers but they can try and
form trimer among themselves and these
trimers from the mesh work on which can
be further connected with the lambing
lattice now the question is we talked
about collagen meshwork and a laminin
lattice but the question is who is
connecting laminin and collagen together
how these two mesh works are connected
so it turns out there are several
cementing molecules which works like
cement like polycon and nitrogen which
connects these two mesh works so Pelican
and nitrogen connect the collagen four
to laminin and remember in laminin we
have several nitrogen and Pelican
interaction domains and also in case in
case of collagen there are several
domains which interacts with these
connective molecules so all these
interactions make the extracellular
matrix are extremely complicated
structure due to this repetitive mesh
work and a strong lattice like structure
it gives a solid base on top of which
epithelial cell layer can build up not
only we are important for a structural
role
it turns out that epithelial cell
epithelial cells received several
proliferative an important signal from
the extracellular matrix so this brings
us to the question of what is the
function of X s Traylor matrix before
going to that I'll stop here in this
video and you have to watch the part two
in order to know this question I hope
you enjoyed my video if you like my
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe and
don't forget to watch the second part of
this video for a complete knowledge
thank you